(pleasant music)
(bell rings)
- Ugh, why won't my photo post?
This is fucking bullshit.
(laughing)
- Hey, can you two keep it down?
I'm trying to get some work done.
- [Woman] Next?
- Hey man how's your coffee?
- Oh it's fantastic.
(pleasant music)
- Not hot enough.
- Why is it so hard to find someone?
- No man, I'm telling you, she's the one.
Seriously.
(buzzing)
Wait wait wait, hold on a second
let me call you back okay?
All right.
Hey, can I just get a beer?
- Can I have another round?
Actually, can you make me a Manhattan?
- Yeah, of course I can.
- So I told her fuck you!
I don't need this shit, get
the hell out of my condo.
(laughing)
You ready?
- This is my fucking
song, are you kidding me?
- Let me give you my number.
- Sure.
(horn blares)
- Asshole, watch where you're going!
- Come on!
♫ Blue skies all the way
♫ We laugh we joke we sing
♫ What a beautiful day
♫ Not a cloud in our sight
♫ It's such an adventure my baby you and I
♫ Waters crystal clear